[Musique]
une convention tout juste signé entre le
département et la fédération française
des services à la personne et de
proximité portant sur la création d'un
centre de formation d'apprentis pour le
secteur des services à la personne
langer s'est tout simplement face au
vieillissement de la population de
permettre de créer des emplois pour les
métiers d'aidé à la personne
petite enfance les aidants familiaux
tous ces emplois de travailler à
domicile et bien doivent être
accompagnés sur le plan de la formation
quoi rendre ces emplois attractifs pour
qu'il y ait des évolutions de carrière
quoi celles et ceux qui occupent des
emplois
donc c'est cela les hors jeu en 2050 le
nombre de personnes âgées de 60 ans et
plus sera de 280 9000 et avec une
demande grandissante des services à la
personne
ce cfa est donc un levier efficace pour
accompagner le vieillissement de la
population
mille personnes seront formées chaque
année au sein de ce cfa
en réponse aux besoins des structures
existantes
le salaire de la personne c'est un
métier qui va vraiment dû du de l'enfant
qui en être au grand âge donc on
s'occupe des personnes de leur naissance
alors décès c'est à dire on va faire la
garde d'enfants à domicile des métiers
de confort du soutien scolaire et après
on va faire l'aide à la personne âgée
l'aide à la personne en suspendant le
cab à domicile dans l'optique de
vraiment aider les personnes à bien
grandir bien vivre et bien vieillir à
domicile
aujourd'hui plus de 80% des français
veulent vieillir à domicile des
formations de niveau 1 au niveau 5
seront proposés par le cfa une offre de
qualification qui s'adressera en grande
partie aux demandeurs d'emploi et aux
aidants familiaux
[Musique]